- Congrats on your Emmy,
"White Lotus," my god.
- [Speaker 1] Yes.
(crowd cheers)
- Thank you.
- [Kumail] So well earned.
- [Murray] Thank you, yeah.
- [Kumail] Wow. So good.
- Yeah, it was a pretty epic
night, that Emmys night,
because we shot "White Lotus"
in the, sort of, the
beginning of the pandemic
and then we didn't really see each other,
that cast, for a long period of time,
'cause we were, you know,
thick in the pandemic.
So the Emmys night, when a
lot of the cast was nominated,
was one of the first times
we were all back together.
So it felt like this
beautiful reunion and then,
you know, we were blessed to
keep winning awards that night.
So it was just this,
like, sort of ramping up
of excitement for us.
- Yeah, he won them all.
(audience whoops)
- It was a bit of a sweep.
I have to say, yeah.
- (laughs)
- It was a bit of a sweep. Well deserved.
- Thank you.
- I mean, that show's
fantastic and you were so good.
(audience cheers and applauds)
- Thank you.
- I remember I ran into you at the airport
the very next day.
- [Murray] Yes.
- [Speaker 1] You did?
- And you were just
there with your backpack
and I was like...
- Randomly.
- (laughs)
- Yeah, I was like,
Where's your Emmy? He's
like, I checked it.
You checked your Emmy?
(audience laughs)
- You did? You didn't
have it in your carry-on?
- No, he didn't!
He just gave it to, like,
"Put this in the bottom of the plane"
- (Laughs)